et puis parallèlement à cette
manifestation cette opération ouverture
des barrières aujourd'hui parler gilet
jaune à l'occasion des départs en
vacances pour de nombreux français
besoin ou vers le péage de saint-arnoult
de 10h à 13h afin de créer des passages
gratuits pour les automobilistes il
s'agit on se rappelle du plus grand ph
d'europe
une opération qui s'est déroulée dans le
calme avec la présence sur place de la
gendarmerie chien alors on est venu au
péage de saint-arnoult pour rendre la
gratuité aux gens qui utilisent les
usagers de l'autoroute
parce que les autoroutes leur
appartiennent depuis longtemps elles
sont payées et voilà c'est un vrai
pouvoir d'achat donc qu'ils garderont
dans leur poche tout simplement voilà et
je pense que c'est un beau petit cadeau
pour les fêtes
il ya beaucoup de gens qui voyagent qui
se réunissent en famille bah voilà tous
les gens qui arrivent sur l'île de
france ils vont le trouver gratuit c'est
le plus grand d'europe et c'est un bon
signe à savoir que le gilet jaune ils
sont toujours là où on demande au peuple
français veut nous donner un coup de
main pour mettre un gros coup d'arrêt à
ces terres n'être qu'une gouvernementale
avoir trouvé notre pouvoir d'achat et
l'autre de l'unité en toiture route et
le dignité w
en tant que le peuple doit retrouver sa
dignité et possède à travers un état
stable à l'économie ça va être dur
délicat il ya certains qui vont
simplement pleuré on a mangé des pâtes
mais à mon avis pour le bien de nos
enfants c'est rien ça on est prêt à
manger un mot de passe pour nous en
fonte à tout cela la basse pour nos
enfants